also joining us from reading is Scott
McLean a spokesman for Cal Fire Scott
good morning thank you so much for
joining us at this point how contained
is the car fire yesterday afternoon late
it was only six percent contained due to
the fire activity during the course of
into the evening when it blew into West
reading where we are standing right now
you can see the fire behind me as
they're doing some firing operations
it's still going to be at 6% probably
even less we keep hearing Scott that the
residents had little warning to evacuate
can you tell us why that is and what's
being done now to guarantee the safety
of those who are there right further
west of here old Shasta and Keswick
areas were evacuated earlier during the
course of yesterday the fire progressed
into those two areas and on all of a
sudden the weather picked up as far as
winds we actually had a few fire
tornadoes within this area that moved
vehicles around broke windows out of the
vehicles that kind of tells you the
ferocity and just the aggressiveness of
this fire that came through this
particular area there was very little
warning because of the speed of that
fire picked up so dramatically
Scott put this fire in context compared
to others that you've seen or others we
might have heard about in other places
fire tornadoes sounds like something we
don't hear about a lot not very often
about six years ago I saw one there very
rare that one it was in Shasta County as
well where we are and that destroyed
about two square miles this one these
were smaller and just moved certain
things around and took a couple tiles
off a roof move some pickups like I said
again it's very erratic winds weather
that promoted very erratic fire behavior
well we know this is dangerous for all
the firefighters out there thank you so
much it's got McLean thank you thank you